Thomas Adler: First question.
Julie Stout: Oh, wait, I gotta do my lead-in.
Thomas Adler: Oh, okay.
Julie Stout: Hello, my name is Julie Stout, I'm here with Thomas Adler. Today is March 26th, 2026, and I am located in Bloomington, Indiana, and Tom, you are in Lexington, Kentucky.
Julie Stout: And we are in part two of our interviews, and where I'm going to dive into the questions about the Dawson Gary project. And without further ado, I can ask you that first question.
Thomas Adler: Sure.
Julie Stout: Awesome.
Julie Stout: So I first want to ask you about your involvement in the project. How did you first become connected to the Dawson Gary project? When, where, and in what capacity?
Thomas Adler: Good question, and I don't remember the details. I told you I would not be remembering a lot of the details.
Thomas Adler: you know, in Dawson's essay that was in Folklore Forum, you know, he… he indicated… he knew that I was, that I came into the, Folklore Institute
Thomas Adler: You know, with an MA from Cooperstown, and he, he knew several other things about me. He knew that I was, already interested in, bluegrass music, and in, in, in general, in,
Thomas Adler: you know, music from, you know, string band music and southern…
Thomas Adler: Southern string band music, Appalachian music, folk music in general, which was not one of his strengths, but… so he knew those things about me, and I don't know if he had that in mind.
Thomas Adler: you know, I don't know whether it was his thought, or into carpenters, or whatever, when he was putting together, what came to be called the Gary Gang, but, but he was looking for, you know, a kind of a range of subject matter expertise in
Thomas Adler: putting together the Gary Gang. So, you know, he wanted people with, interests in
Thomas Adler: in a variety of fields, and I guess I was the guy, you know, he said right in his essay in the, Folklore Forum that, you know, I was there sort of to… to, to meet with, you know.
Thomas Adler: southern, you know, with the hillbillies that had come into the Calumet region. Which, by the way, early on, we all called Da region.
Thomas Adler: As if it was pronounced D-A-D region.
Thomas Adler: And so, I don't recall our very first meetings about that at all, whether it was with INTA, or Dawson or the whole group.
Thomas Adler: This would have to have been around 1975 or early 76, somewhere in that time period.
Thomas Adler: at the Folklore Institute. And again, as someone who came in with an MA, you know, most students who arrived at the Folklore Institute had to take, there was some core classes, and I forget what they were called, it was like Theory and Practice of Folklore or something like that.
Thomas Adler: which I didn't have to take. People that came in with an MA didn't necessarily take those sort of introductory graduate courses in folklore.
Thomas Adler: So I didn't have those, and those were, those courses, you know, Dawson had a big part in those, so I didn't have, early on, you know, the classes with Dawson that most new students would have had with him. So I honestly don't…
Thomas Adler: recall, you know, the, the precise connection to the Gary Gang or the Gary project right at the beginning.
Julie Stout: So you didn't have to take, like, a fieldwork course or anything? So you… but had you done fieldwork before this?
Thomas Adler: Absolutely, at Cooperstown, yes.
Julie Stout: Oh, yes, yes,
Thomas Adler: And, yeah, so… so I came in with some experience at those things, and in fact, Cooperstown, I may have mentioned before, you know, they… they had not only, you know, sort of exposed us to that, but they had a series of… of, what they called practicums
Thomas Adler: at Cooperstown, where they… they really…
Thomas Adler: You know, kind of took us through the basics of
Thomas Adler: photography and recording, you know, audio recording, video recording, basics, you know, but we knew by the… you know, before I ever got to the Folklore Institute, I knew how to deal with a camera.
Thomas Adler: and, had a, you know, a 35mm camera, knew kind of what to do with it. So, didn't have to be taught those things at… in Bloomington.
Thomas Adler: and had done some field work. You know, I still have photos that I took in Cooperstown, and as I think I already told you, I wish I had copies of the photos that I took when I was in Gary. You have access to that… those materials, and I don't, but
Thomas Adler: You know, to move on to the next question, what were my primary responsibilities and roles?
Thomas Adler: again, I was sort of the guy to go there and find the hillbillies in the region.
Thomas Adler: you know, or the southern migrants into the area, and there were certain parts of the area, of the Calumet region, that were reputed to be strong with Southern immigrants in Hobart and other areas up there.
Thomas Adler: And so I concentrated on trying to meet people there, and, you know, hung out at some… some bars with
Thomas Adler: You know, where… where… Folks like that that were interested in, in,
Thomas Adler: In, country music and hillbilly music were, reputed to hang out, you know?
Thomas Adler: And, there was… I think I mentioned in my essay, there was a guy I already knew named Craig Jones. He had been a bass player in Bloomington in a band that I was part of in Bloomington. So I had a contact
Thomas Adler: You know, who…
Thomas Adler: helped point me in… in some directions. I didn't work a lot with Craig, but he said, oh, you ought to go to that bar, you know, and… and so that was helpful, too. But,
Thomas Adler: You know, to move to… right to the next question, and what were the project's aims at the start, and how did those evolve? I don't know that they did evolve a lot, except for us individually, as we made discoveries around
Thomas Adler: The region, you know, of… learned where to go, what was productive, and what wasn't.
Thomas Adler: most of the time, I think most of us worked alone or in very small groups. I worked some with Richard March, and
Thomas Adler: you know, Dawson relates that time that March and I,
Thomas Adler: He took a video recorder down on… on the…
Thomas Adler: what's the street? Broadway or something, in Gary, and we had this video equipment, and people came up to us thinking we were TV guys, you know, and…
Thomas Adler: So… but that didn't change our goals. We wanted to talk to people and ask them about the area, you know, and meet folks, whatever they were interested in. Now, I didn't concentrate on, you know, say, steel workers or anything. When we were doing, sort of, generalized
Thomas Adler: inquiries like that. You know, that… our goal was to… to get to know
Thomas Adler: folks that lived in the area, regardless… whether they were, again, from my perspective, whether they fit that… that rubric of Southern in-migrants who had settled in the Calumet region or not. You know, we were trying to… to meet
Thomas Adler: People that knew the area, and get a sense of what they thought of the area.
Thomas Adler: In what their… their sense was of their… of, you know, the traditions of the area. What did they call it, you know? And some of them were defensive about it, and said, oh, this is the armpit of the state, this is a terrible place, and other people said, no, this is… this is a pretty good place.
Thomas Adler: Some pointed out, you know, Gary had a reputation for being crime-ridden.
Thomas Adler: You know, there was a certain amount of racial conflict in Gary that was well known, not only in the Calumet region, but beyond that. I had heard about that growing up in Chicago, that Gary
Thomas Adler: and the northwest part of Indiana was a place with a certain amount of racial tension between blacks and whites. But we weren't, you know, deliberately looking for
Thomas Adler: For that, but we wanted to hear whatever people had to say.
Julie Stout: Can I ask a quick follow-up question on that?
Thomas Adler: Horse.
Julie Stout: I know that, Dawson kind of wanted each student to maybe, perhaps take on, like, different sections of what he thought that they would be able to, like, dive into. Like, I know John Hassey was doing stuff with, like, Black gospel music.
Julie Stout: Richard March was, like, the Croatian-Serbian community, and also some music background.
Julie Stout: you also have that music background, and you mentioned going to, like, the bars, and potentially speaking with musicians. Was your area… oh, and the hillbilly… the hillabilly population?
Thomas Adler: Well, Southern, southern…
Julie Stout: Southern, okay, yeah, so it's southern… southern.
Thomas Adler: For Southern in-migrants, more broadly.
Julie Stout: Southern migrants, what was that experience for you?
Julie Stout: Did you, like, did you go into the project, like, knowing, like, for sure that this was the community that you knew you were kind of recruited to, like, dive into? Or it evolved over time as you did it and everything?
Thomas Adler: No, I think I knew that…
Thomas Adler: What they were asking of me, partly.
Julie Stout: Hmm.
Thomas Adler: look for Southern… mostly, you know, white Southerners that lived in the region that
Thomas Adler: that lived there that probably had either come into that region, you know, and the assumption was people were there, you know, looking for work. You know, in the Calumont region, as in so many other parts of the, you know, the Midwest,
Thomas Adler: there had been a lot of migration from… from the Upper South into,
Thomas Adler: you know, into Ohio, into Michigan, you know, and that story is very important for,
Thomas Adler: Country music and bluegrass in general,
Thomas Adler: So, you know, to this day, people talk about
Thomas Adler: Well, you know, a real hearth for bluegrass music was Southwest Ohio, you know, because folks came from Kentucky, you know, there's songs about reading and writing, and Route 23 was how you got out of Kentucky, and where did it take you? It took you into Ohio.
Thomas Adler: You know, or farther north, you know, and so those folks came into,
Thomas Adler: into, Columbus and Cincinnati, or farther north, and some of those same people, you know, ended up in the Calumet region.
Thomas Adler: You know, and so I had a sense that that's what I was there to find, or the demographic that I was there to explore. But not necessarily all musicians, only even though that was my interest and background. It was…
Thomas Adler: you know, white Southern end migrants.
Thomas Adler: If I can put it that way.
Thomas Adler: I don't know if that answers the question the way you asked it, but…
Julie Stout: Oh, yeah, it definitely did.
Julie Stout: Thank you for clarifying as well.
Thomas Adler: You… your next question on this interview list says, how did the project fit within IU and the broader community at the time? I don't know how much the folks, the rest of the folks.
Thomas Adler: in the Folklore Institute even knew about what we were doing, about the Gary gang.
Thomas Adler: I mean, we were a small group, what, 8 or so people, and Dawson… I don't know how much Dawson even talked about it.
Thomas Adler: To… at… at large, you know, if… was he telling new…
Thomas Adler: you know, newly, enrolled folklore students or something like that, that he was embarked on this project? I don't even know. So I don't know if there was a great awareness of the Gary gang at the time, until after it got done and we wrote up things, and…
Thomas Adler: You know, we wrote our papers, and that ended up being in… published in that,
Thomas Adler: journal for… mostly for folklore students, Folklore Forum, and
Thomas Adler: And then Dawson, a year or so later, a year or two, whenever it was, published his book, Land of the Millrats,
Thomas Adler: So, but I don't think there was a big stir about a group of us going off to the Calumet region to do field work.
Julie Stout: It's… it's interesting, because I remember when I asked Richard March a similar question, he said… oh, and Richard Verdutis said something as well, in where…
Julie Stout: It was kind of a unique…
Julie Stout: Idea for a faculty member to recruit grad students.
Julie Stout: To kind of, like, hone in on specific areas that they think that they would mesh well with.
Julie Stout: Do you think that was kind of, like, revolutionary for the time, or… what's your impression of that, I think?
Thomas Adler: Well, I'm not aware of other… other faculty members doing things like that.
Julie Stout: Yeah, she did that, yeah.
Thomas Adler: So… so, yeah, I don't know if I… if it was revolutionary or not, but Dawson, you know, Dawson had that notion, and he was… he was, you know.
Thomas Adler: kind of interested at that time, I mean, in the mid-70s, in that whole question of, you know, is there a folk in the city? You know, was sort of the question, and…
Thomas Adler: And so this was part of his way of trying to answer that question. And so…
Thomas Adler: You know, and he said he wasn't trying to build a team that he would lead exactly, so he wanted some experienced, graduate students, folklore graduate students, who had enough experience on their own that we could go out and… he trusted us to go out and
Thomas Adler: Do some work that would produce results that
Thomas Adler: he might find interesting, you know? And he himself, of course, spent a lot of time there in the Calumet region.
Thomas Adler: So… You know, that's the best I can answer that question.
Thomas Adler: Let's see… who were the key people or groups I worked with, and what did each contribute?
Julie Stout: We'll touch on this a little bit, but this is one of my favorite questions, because feel free to weave in anecdotes or memories that you might associate with that, because I find… I found that in talking to the other students, they have…
Julie Stout: some of the more interesting, like, memories spark with that, because they remember, certain people they interviewed, or, like, something that they… that stood out to them. So feel free to, take that as you will.
Julie Stout: remember.
Thomas Adler: Again, I can't remember a lot. I mean, there were…
Julie Stout: years ago.
Thomas Adler: The interactions I had were often brief ones, you know? I spent some time at the homes of a few folks that I met.
Thomas Adler: But, it seemed very,
Thomas Adler: fairly, superficial to me in a lot of ways. When I met these… met these folks, you know, they would… they would tell me.
Thomas Adler: you know, kind of what they… what they were doing. You know, the musicians would tell me kind of what the… what kind of music they had done before they got, or what they were involved in.
Thomas Adler: you know, members of a band at, say, that bar that Craig Jones took me to. You know, they would tell me a little bit about themselves, but it's not like I would, you know, come back and visit them repeatedly and really get to know them. So it was… it felt…
Thomas Adler: as I say, a little bit superficial.
Thomas Adler: You know, and the region itself was so big and complex, that it was…
Thomas Adler: You know, it felt like there… in a way, there wasn't time to…
Thomas Adler: You know, to really get to know someone and, and…
Thomas Adler: dwell with them, you know, a lot, and come back. You know, and nobody seemed like a, you know, the kind of,
Thomas Adler: of contact.
Thomas Adler: that… that warranted, you know, many repeat visits. You know, they would say interesting things, and, you know, you would make notes, or take a picture, or record something, but it was,
Thomas Adler: As I say, when I use the word superficial, I don't mean trivial, but not… it wasn't deep, it was… it was like,
Thomas Adler: sort of a scattershot approach. We were… we were looking at things. You know, I did… I've done fieldwork projects,
Thomas Adler: not much later than that for the Library of Congress in, in, the,
Thomas Adler: In South Central Georgia, the Library of Congress had a project there that I worked on, and in the Blue Ridge, along the Blue Ridge Parkway.
Thomas Adler: And those two, you know, you… there were some folks on those projects that I did go back to repeatedly, because I had some things that I was particularly pursuing,
Thomas Adler: that I wasn't interested in, or pursuing when I was in Gary, or in the Calumet region. And so.
Thomas Adler: You know, and that made a difference. You know, when I was in South Georgia, for example, I knew that I was particularly… I was especially interested in traditional foodways down there. That didn't enter my mind at all in the Gary region. It might have been interesting had I…
Thomas Adler: been looking at that, but I was… I was more focused, as I say, on southern
Thomas Adler: migration, or Southern Inn migrants, and… and, you know, food didn't really come up, and I wasn't asking questions along those lines, so,
Thomas Adler: So, you know, I didn't get contributions, or… I didn't ask the questions and didn't get information from them along those lines.
Thomas Adler: the people that I talked to, the musicians, would tell me about, you know, their instruments or the groups that they
Thomas Adler: They were… had been part of, or were still part of, but
Thomas Adler: as I say, it felt a little bit superficial. It's like, oh yeah, play with so-and-so, but he used to play with that guy, you know? It didn't feel very deep, any of that.
Thomas Adler: Let's see, what approaches fieldwork documentation, archiving did the project use, and why? Well, we did use,
Thomas Adler: We did use… You know, a bunch of equipment
Thomas Adler: Beyond… beyond our own cameras, You know, and
Thomas Adler: some… some equipment that… that the Folklore Institute supplied. There is those funny anecdotes in the write-up about, things that broke, you know, Dawson broke one camera, and things… things…
Thomas Adler: Things would fail, as they often do, you know, when you're out there where something…
Thomas Adler: you know, won't, you know, that you're counting on just won't work right. We didn't have a,
Thomas Adler: anyone guiding us in terms of the equipment, the technology, and the use of equipment. Again, if I compare and contrast this with the Library of Congress projects that came later in my career.
Thomas Adler: Those things, in those projects.
Thomas Adler: we always had the amazing help of Carl Fleischauer. I don't know if that's a name you know, but Carl was at the Library of Congress. I don't know if he's retired if he's there still, but he is an astonishing photographer in his own right.
Thomas Adler: And very much attuned to the technology of recording things, whether it's video, especially photography. And he was there
Thomas Adler: on those… Library of Congress projects every day exhorting all of us to Take more pictures.
Thomas Adler: here's what you should be doing more of with your photography. He was… he was a real, counselor about doing… using the technology in our fieldwork. He didn't tell us, kind of, what to do.
Thomas Adler: Except to say, you can't go back, take more pictures. He was… he was…
Thomas Adler: constant about that. It's like, you know, you're never gonna go back to this. So, if you're photographing, whether it's a person showing you something, or a barn, or a quilt, or a pie safe, or, you know, whatever it is.
Thomas Adler: don't be satisfied with one shot. Well, we didn't have that kind of guidance on the Gary project. We didn't have anyone
Thomas Adler: Really haranguing us about
Thomas Adler: the way to document things, and how to do our fieldwork to a higher standard. We were more or less assumed
Thomas Adler: to be able to do it to a proper standard ourselves, and I think, for the most part, we did, but…
Thomas Adler: But it wasn't… it wasn't… We weren't instructed in that exactly. We were… we were, I think.
Thomas Adler: Told that we could do it.
Thomas Adler: As to archiving, that was left for later. We weren't involved in that.
Thomas Adler: Let's see, how, ethics and consent.
Julie Stout: I had a, go ahead. Quick follow-up on the other one.
Julie Stout: You, I think, are the only student that I've talked to thus far that has… well, actually, Richard Verdutas had some, like, video experience before as well. But you came in with experience with some equipment and cameras and stuff of the like.
Julie Stout: How much did it differ from the equipment that you used on the Gary project, and… didn't differ.
Julie Stout: And what was that experience like for you?
Thomas Adler: Well, the equipment itself was different. I mean, it was a different generation of…
Thomas Adler: you know, the video equipment that we had, when I was at Cooperstown in 1970 and 71, it was a different generation of video
Thomas Adler: equipment than what we had in 1976, you know, 75, 6, 7. So, the… the actual
Thomas Adler: equipment was different. The cameras, the 35mm cameras were similar, and they were our own cameras. We weren't issued equipment by the Folklore Institute, so…
Thomas Adler: at least that I recall, so I think I was using my own Minalta camera.
Thomas Adler: you know, and you know, there were the,
Thomas Adler: again, on later projects, under the advice of the man I just mentioned at the Library of Congress, Carl Fleischauer, he… he was… he was so technologically astute, you know, he,
Thomas Adler: He was… he was very demanding, too, when it came to doing video as opposed to photography.
Thomas Adler: You know, he was, he was…
Thomas Adler: he taught us things on those later projects that no one had ever mentioned, neither at Cooperstown nor on the Gary project about the demands of video. I mean, he was acutely aware of lighting and audio in ways that nobody
Thomas Adler: had ever advised me before. So, video is much, much more complicated to do a good job
Thomas Adler: than photography, and as I say, Carl Fleischauer himself is a…
Thomas Adler: absolutely brilliant photographer, who has put out books, on his own and in collaboration with other scholars, as a documentary photographer. So.
Thomas Adler: We didn't have anyone like that advising us.
Thomas Adler: So…
Thomas Adler: I think, and likewise, when it comes to the, you know, I was starting to turn to that next question about permissions, confidentiality.
Thomas Adler: and all that. I don't recall that we had any kind of permission slips, or…
Thomas Adler: you know, if we did, I've completely forgotten about that. If we had any,
Thomas Adler: anything, you know, confidential. Dawson mentions in his write-up about the Gary gang that he at first didn't, you know, he had an encounter where people asked him for a card, a business card, which he didn't have.
Thomas Adler: we didn't have, at least not at first. I don't recall if we were ever given any. If we had been, I think I would have kept one, but I don't have anything from the Gary gang, from the Gary project. So I don't know that we ever got… we field workers ever got cards that said.
Thomas Adler: Indiana University, you know, project, or anything like that.
Thomas Adler: So, I think it was really pretty much my memory…
Thomas Adler: as bad as it is about all this is that we didn't have that kind of paperwork. We were really just doing this,
Thomas Adler: you know, conversationally with people we would meet, you know, and explain to them what we were all about, and is it okay if I, record you a little bit, or take your picture? And people would say yes, for almost always. We would do that.
Thomas Adler: But I don't recall permission slips, you know, or or, or,
Thomas Adler: You know, again, confidentiality. Nothing came up, you know, in what I was doing, where people were concerned about
Thomas Adler: you know, remaining confidential, like, keep this secret, or can you turn that tape recorder off now? That… that… I don't remember anything like that coming up then and there.
Thomas Adler: Some of those things happen on later projects that I was involved in, but
Thomas Adler: But not in the Gary project. So…
Thomas Adler: how were ethical considerations handled? Maybe not at all.
Julie Stout: It was an interesting question, I wanted to ask you, because…
Julie Stout: In our time today, it's very different, right?
Thomas Adler: Oh, yeah.
Julie Stout: yeah, there's papers for everything, documentation for everything, and so I can say that other students also said what you said. They didn't remember any kind of paper, or, like, release form, or, copyright release form, like, I have you have signed for this, and everything. There's nothing like that.
Julie Stout: And it was… Based on conversations and getting consent verbally.
Julie Stout: And going off of that. And so, your account does echo what other people have told me, but I find it interesting to reflect on in relation to today's time as well. Oh, yeah. And do you think you would do it differently, if you went back, or would you…
Thomas Adler: Yeah, possibly. It depends… it depends on how deep a contact I would have with… with a given person.
Thomas Adler: It's,
Thomas Adler: You know, much later, in the early 2000s, I wrote this book that was a history of Bill Monroe's Music Park.
Thomas Adler: and did many, many, many interviews with people, and I… I made up my own permission forms, because I knew I was going to quote them in the book, and so I… I had a permission form
Thomas Adler: for that, because I wanted to be sure that I had the permission to quote people. If I… you know, long before I actually wrote the book, I wanted to know that I could quote them.
Thomas Adler: You know, without getting sued or having people annoyed at me. So I did that, but that was in 2000… between 2000 and 2010 or so, you know, 30 years after the Gary project.
Thomas Adler: You know, I think we've become more aware of the need to… to have these kinds of,
Thomas Adler: permissions or… or be aware of the need for confidentiality in certain circumstances, and… and I certainly had
Thomas Adler: again, later on, not… I don't recall this happening in Gary, but, you know, in my later folklore work, or interviewing work, I've definitely had situations where people wanted something to be confidential. I'd be running a tape recorder, and they would… they would often just say.
Thomas Adler: Turn that off. I want to talk to you about something. Turn that off now. This is off the record.
Thomas Adler: So, they would enforce confidentiality in that way, you know, and then I would ask for a signed permission form for what they did let me record. That didn't happen in… on the Gary project.
Thomas Adler: As far as I can recall.
Thomas Adler: Let me see… Milestones, pivotal events.
Thomas Adler: Or decisions that shape the project's direction or outcomes.
Thomas Adler: I don't know that I can provide anything there.
Julie Stout: That one has been an interesting question, because…
Julie Stout: The students, there were… there were… there was collaboration between you sometimes.
Thomas Adler: Yeah.
Julie Stout: Travel together, or something of the like.
Julie Stout: But as for people, for the most part, from what I was understanding, is that a lot of it was individual. Yes. And so when you're talking about milestones or pivotal events, I think that's entirely individual to the research and people you were talking to and stuff of the like.
Julie Stout: And so, as I was… been talking to you all, I've been realizing that over time, it's truly individual. It's truly subjective to your perspective, and so…
Julie Stout: it's been an interesting one to dive into and ask about that, because it's really only Dawson who would really know.
Julie Stout: pivotal events and milestones and outcomes, but sadly, he's no longer with us. Right. And so…
Julie Stout: to get your perspective on it is our next greatest thing that we can do when reflecting on the project itself. And so, yeah, and so your response is appreciated for however you want to answer things. Yeah.
Julie Stout: Yeah. Yeah.
Thomas Adler: Let's see, one or two moments that capture the project's spirit or challenges. Well, it was all challenging. You know, the,
Thomas Adler: Dawson mentions in his essay,
Thomas Adler: you know, hotel or motel that, you know, some people stayed at. I remember staying at a Red Roof Inn that's still on the outskirts of Gary, or by Crown Point, or somewhere like that. That motel is still there, and
Thomas Adler: I remember…
Thomas Adler: You know, that that was… this isn't a great story, but they were… it was a hard place to deal with, just because, you know, they… they didn't… if… if anyone ever called.
Thomas Adler: you know, you could… you wouldn't get a message. You know, they just… they didn't… their switchboard, or whatever it was, was absolutely unreliable.
Thomas Adler: So, if anyone called me.
Thomas Adler: at… at that motel, forget it, you know, they didn't reach me, or… or one time out of four or five, you know, it just… it didn't happen very well. So, that was…
Thomas Adler: you know, that was one of the challenges of staying at that particular place.
Thomas Adler: You know, another… I mean, it was nice to work with, with,
Thomas Adler: you know, Richard March. I haven't seen March in some years now, but
Thomas Adler: we used to call him Marchovich, you know, sometimes. And he's a great guy, you know, we were friends, and I remember, you know, going to, some restaurants just for our own lunch and things like that, and he had… he always had great ideas about,
Thomas Adler: you know, good Croatian food and stuff like that, and he would…
Thomas Adler: you know, he knew, of course, those ethnic things that I didn't know about with my very limited background. Again, I had told you my parents were Austrian refugees, so I had a little…
Thomas Adler: European perspective, but ultimately very different from Richard's, and you know, complimentary, but in a different way, and
Thomas Adler: You know, so that was… you know, the spirit was… was wonderful to work with him, you know, and
Thomas Adler: you know, and likewise, I got along very well with John Hassey, you know, and
Thomas Adler: we had been friends in Bloomington, you know. He knew that I came over to… he played piano quite a bit in Nashville, you know, and I went over there a lot because I would be going to Bean Blossom, to the music park there, and
Thomas Adler: I probably saw him, you know, at least a couple of times when he was playing.
Thomas Adler: piano, you know, in Nashville. He was… he was there earning some money, and…
Thomas Adler: And, he enjoyed playing, and he was very good.
Thomas Adler: We weren't… we weren't the closest of friends, but we always got along, you know, so it was nice
Thomas Adler: knowing John… I know… I think I knew March… and… and Hassie, better than…
Thomas Adler: most anyone else on the project, I mean, in terms of our…
Thomas Adler: prior relationships, and so that, that was,
Thomas Adler: you know, the spirit of the project. We all were cordial enough, you know, the times we got together in Bloomington, which were not all that frequent.
Thomas Adler: Again, in my memory, you know, there were a few meetings, but
Thomas Adler: But it was, you know, the challenges were often caused by the fact that we were going off in different directions in this very large and complicated urban environment.
Thomas Adler: It could take a long time just to get to where you were going in that environment, just to drive
Thomas Adler: you know, from the Red Roof Inn to, East Whiting or something could take you 45 minutes or an hour, or longer if the traffic was bad, so it was,
Thomas Adler: it was a challenging environment compared with Bloomington in the 70s.
Thomas Adler: But it was,
Thomas Adler: the spirit was generally pretty good, you know, among us all. We were pleased to be doing the work, or attempting to do the work, but
Thomas Adler: Anyway…
Thomas Adler: Let's see. What materials, photos, recordings, documents would I highlight for preservation, and where are they housed? You know better than I do where they're housed. And since I don't have copies.
Thomas Adler: I would think they should all be preserved, honestly. Whatever exists should be preserved. I think I told you that I stayed on at Cooperstown after the first year of that program as an archivist, and so I believe very strongly in archiving
Thomas Adler: general… in general, and I've never studied library science as you have, but
Thomas Adler: archiving and libraries are near and dear to my heart, so I… you know, the preservation of this sort of material, of all sorts of academic material, and especially on a project like this.
Thomas Adler: You don't want to think of it all as just ephemeral that it happened and it's gone forever, so you know better than I, you know, where the remaining recordings and documents exist, and I believe it all should be preserved, whatever is there.
Thomas Adler: And I hope you'll point some of it to me, because I'd very much like to see it, or… or get to it.
Julie Stout: Did you have a favorite medium of documentation, whether that be video recording, photographs? What was your favorite thing to do during the.
Thomas Adler: I think photographs.
Julie Stout: Good.
Thomas Adler: Partly because, it's, in a way, the simplest thing to do when you don't know… when you're not, deeply connected to the
Thomas Adler: To the locale and the subject matter, or even the people.
Thomas Adler: You know, it's easy enough, you know, unless someone says, don't take my picture, it's easy enough to get pictures of people in their settings. And the place itself is,
Thomas Adler: is fascinating. I mean, so you can… you can get pictures, certainly, of ethnic restaurants, and the mills, and the, you know, the place itself, and… and, I forget if we took pictures of things like the,
Thomas Adler: there's a bridge whose name I'm now forgetting, or spacing out on the,
Thomas Adler: It's a screaming bridge, you know, there is a bridge that… with a legend about a…
Thomas Adler: You know, it's a wailing woman, Ghost, you know.
Julie Stout: It's not La Llorona, is it?
Thomas Adler: Well, it's related to the La Llorona.
Julie Stout: Okay, okay, okay, because, like, I'm trying to rack my brain, because I was just looking at your photographs last week, and I do remember a bridge.
Julie Stout: Did you also take pictures of the, like, industry, like, the steel industries and everything?
Thomas Adler: Probably.
Julie Stout: Yeah, because there's, like, some factories as well, next, and, like, smokestacks and stuff like that.
Julie Stout: you do have a whole file that I can direct you to in the future.
Thomas Adler: Yeah, well, Refresh my memory to see.
Julie Stout: Yes, yeah, yeah.
Thomas Adler: But yeah, there, there are those, those places and things, so… You know, again, it's a…
Thomas Adler: it's hard for me to remember without seeing those, those, materials. But yeah, photography was probably the easiest, medium, you know, for me.
Thomas Adler: You know, because you can do that whether there are people involved or not, you know, and as a way to record the look of the place.
Thomas Adler: Let's see, what were the toughest hurdles? Logistical, funding, interpersonal, will…
Thomas Adler: I don't remember any special funding problems, no real interpersonal problems, except, as I said, we were working
Thomas Adler: you know, we may have been the gang, you know, but we were more or less separate as researchers. So, you know, there weren't interpersonal problems that I recall. I don't think anyone was… had any antipathies against anyone else in the group.
Thomas Adler: But logistically, you know, getting around, like I say, you know, I couldn't rely on the…
Thomas Adler: the switchboard at the motel to relay messages or anything like that. That's kind of a logistical thing, a challenge. Minor, perhaps, but…
Thomas Adler: You know, if you're waiting for some… someone that you thought was gonna get back to you, and they never do, is it their fault, or is it the switchboard at the motel?
Thomas Adler: Impact, Legacy, and Reflections.
Julie Stout: I had one more… I'm so sorry, I didn't.
Thomas Adler: Sure, interrupt, absolutely.
Julie Stout: I'm interrupting. You did fieldwork before, and extensive fieldwork at that, because I remember you got really close to the people that you were working with, if I'm remembering that correctly.
Thomas Adler: Yeah, in New York.
Julie Stout: And yeah, in New York and everything. My follow-up to that is, because you came in with experience.
Julie Stout: What did you learn
Julie Stout: more from this Gary Project fieldwork experience that you didn't have in your previous fieldwork experience, if any? Is there anything that you wish that you knew before diving into the Gary Project?
Thomas Adler: Wow.
Thomas Adler: Well, I wish… I wish I had had… You know,
Thomas Adler: Again, I think I told you, when I was in Cooperstown, one of my main faculty members
Thomas Adler: Really pointed me to a particularly helpful And friendly, man that became…
Thomas Adler: Not only an informant, but ultimately a friend.
Thomas Adler: And…
Thomas Adler: And that made a big difference. You know, I was able to spend a lot of time with this man.
Thomas Adler: And,
Thomas Adler: And, you know, he spent a lot of time… he and his wife spent time with me and my future wife, who was at Cooperstown.
Thomas Adler: And… And so, it became a fairly deep relationship there.
Thomas Adler: And… in Gary, or in the region there, There was no…
Thomas Adler: There were no deep relationships. There was no time to establish any. If I… if I had had…
Thomas Adler: I told you that there was one guy, you know, that introduced me to a… that I had known a little bit before in Bloomington, who pointed me to a certain bar where I'd hear country music and maybe meet some more musicians.
Thomas Adler: But I didn't have a real deep connection with him, either. I mean, we had played a little music together, but I think it would have been very helpful to have someone with a truly deep connection to the region.
Thomas Adler: you know, that I could go back to and maybe work with much more deeply, and continuously.
Thomas Adler: I think that could have made a big difference.
Thomas Adler: In my work, if there was sort of a,
Thomas Adler: I wouldn't call them a star informant, but an inside informant for me, instead of just striking out on my own with this general
Thomas Adler: quest for Southern in-migrants, especially musicians, but not… not exclusively musicians.
Thomas Adler: It would have helped a lot to have… to have that kind of…
Thomas Adler: local connection, you know, something… something deeper.
Thomas Adler: I… this is in retrospect. I didn't feel that way at the time, but I… I'm just thinking back about what might have helped. So…
Thomas Adler: What lasting impacts?
Thomas Adler: stand out.
Thomas Adler: for participants IU in the field, and what lessons or advice would I pass on to future stewards? Well.
Thomas Adler: I would say that, you know, in a way, echoing what I just said, that if someone is
Thomas Adler: is doing…
Thomas Adler: a project in a region that they're not already familiar with, it would be very helpful. Several things that I've just mentioned, I think, would be quite helpful. One would be,
Thomas Adler: the,
Thomas Adler: To the extent that technology plays a part, and it does more and more as time goes on.
Thomas Adler: A technological advisor, a really top-notch advisor.
Thomas Adler: If we're gonna do photography or videography, recording, audio recording,
Thomas Adler: documentation of any kind. Someone that's really…
Thomas Adler: first rate at the use of those technologies should be part of the team, not necessarily as a
Thomas Adler: Content person, but as an advisor on doing you know, on…
Thomas Adler: dealing with the technology that you're trying to use to do that sort of field work. I think that's important. And the other thing is the point that I just made, that
Thomas Adler: Going into a region, if… if one has the time, either already has
Thomas Adler: A local contact or informant with whom one is already well connected, or has the time to develop a deep connection with someone
Thomas Adler: That has the… that's,
Thomas Adler: You know, in the genre or area that one is most interested in.
Thomas Adler: if someone has that connection. I don't know, for example, if John Hassey
Thomas Adler: you know, in coming into a Black church, if he had a special contact with any particular preacher or not, you know?
Thomas Adler: you're shaking your head no. And… and he's a… he's a great field worker, and a good…
Thomas Adler: you know, good operative in all sorts of contexts, but I just… I can't help but think that having that kind of contact
Thomas Adler: Going into a, a, a,
Thomas Adler: an exploratory project could be a great help. So that would be…
Thomas Adler: the advice I would give for future
Thomas Adler: Members of a project like this.
Thomas Adler: If that's possible.
Julie Stout: It's,
Julie Stout: it was kind of a common theme I kind of picked up as I talked to everyone, was…
Julie Stout: Everyone but Richard Verdutas had a contact.
Julie Stout: because Richard Verdunas is from the region, and so he was kind of the exemplary person on the team, for lack of a better phrase, that…
Julie Stout: News more than the other students.
Julie Stout: And…
Julie Stout: to your point about John Hasse, he had quite a few anecdotes of, like, his experiences in these black churches, and being called up to the front, and he was really nervous and everything to play the piano, but he was really grateful as well.
Julie Stout: And it's a learning experience, I'm sure, as well. It's a… it's a growing experience, like, meeting new people, talking to new people, but also remaining true to, like.
Julie Stout: The notion that you want to learn, you want to know more, which is always so important.
Thomas Adler: Yeah.
Julie Stout: My last question for you is…
Julie Stout: Any other reflections? Any other reflections from the Gary Project? Any other things you'd like to share? It can be anything, you can think of.
Julie Stout: And… I really liked your notes on your relationships with the other students as well. I thought that was really nice, a nice touch as well.
Thomas Adler: Well, I, you know, again, just by comparison with the Library of Congress projects that I worked on.
Thomas Adler: On those projects, not only did we create a whole lot of photographs and audio recordings, things like that, but we got copies of all of that.
Thomas Adler: So… or as much of it as we wanted. So,
Thomas Adler: I wish that had been the case on the Gary project. Now, I know you're going to point me to some of the preserved materials,
Thomas Adler: But I think that's… that's very helpful, you know, even though it's been decades since the Gary gang
Thomas Adler: ventured forth. I wish I had those materials. It certainly probably would have stimulated my memory a little more.
Thomas Adler: So, I think… I think it, you know, I think it would help…
Thomas Adler: Field workers to know that the materials they generate are
Thomas Adler: VERA materials, as well as things that are going into an archive. You know, so the things I did for the Library of Congress are in the,
Thomas Adler: the, Library of Congress, the,
Thomas Adler: you know, the Archive of Folk Culture.
Thomas Adler: And… and they're there, and, they've been…
Thomas Adler: You know, very carefully, not only preserved, but indexed, and they're, they're findable.
Thomas Adler: And it's great to know that, and I don't know… I, I wi- I wish…
Thomas Adler: You know, and I have copies of many of the tapes and photos,
Thomas Adler: from those later projects. I wish that were the case for the Gary materials as well.
Thomas Adler: Maybe that's just a more personal wish, you know, than anything else.
Julie Stout: I think that your comment points into the exact point of this project that I hope it to be, which is to make it more findable, make it more public.
Thomas Adler: Oh, yeah.
Julie Stout: know this exists, and so I think your wish is a very pointed one to what I'm trying to do with it. So I think it makes perfect sense to me, and thank you for sharing that as well.
Thomas Adler: Sure.
Julie Stout: That was the last of my questions for the Gary project, and if you don't have anything else, we can move on to the next section.
Thomas Adler: Nick Dawson!
Julie Stout: into Dawson! So I'm gonna stop this one here, and we can go to the next one.